hi guys it's silver at again with
another tutorial episode and today I'm
going to add a wall to this path thing I
don't even know what to call it's it's
it's a cliff side path and it's going to
be like this point where you can look at
the coaster and be like wow husk that's
awesome basically because this is an
awesome cut no wait never mind
haha [ __ ] I was digressing way too much
okay so for the walls I'm going to use
shy ghost planters basically because
this set is made to have them pretty
much the same placements as shyguy
splinters and that's why I like to use
it but I also like to use sugar
splinters because it has a really nice
rocky texture and it's not very
repetitive it's a pretty big war as well
so you don't have to place many things
it's not like this one h1 why you'd have
to place many 1h walls to make it high
so that's it's very user friendly it
looks good and it kind of fits the theme
plus I'm planning on adding rockwork
later on over here just to make this
look a bit nicer and some semi tropical
foliage or whatever I'm going to do so
this this suits that perfectly so I'm
just going to at this all right this
thing just to cover up that ugly in-game
kind of I don't even know cliff side
okay and now the curved part which is
pretty much the same as the paths you
have these straight to diagonals you've
got a and B I do think they flipped a MB
er what's B in this set it's actually
it's actually a inch I got splinters but
that's not too big of a deal it's it's
something to remember though because if
you know that you can use these this set
quicker because you know you know which
piece to take okay so now I'm going to
take the curved two piece and just add
it over here well that's starting to
look pretty good already and I need the
diagonal piece for this empty space okay
and a half piece over here to fill in
the gap
okay and normal piece over here it's
it's basically the same thing all over
the place
oh and don't worry about the the weird
transitions and this part just ending
somewhere because I'm going to add some
rock work or other things to just cover
that up actually I am going to make this
place a bit higher as well actually yeah
I'm going to extend this let's see I
think that works fine I guess yeah that
should work I am actually going to make
a bit lower though because this is a
very large straight point and that's
kind of boring let's see oh God
terraforming know what's going to mess
up well whatever you can always just use
the smoothing tool though I should not
smooth it anywhere near the support
because that's going to mess them up and
I should not do that either Wow just
gonna use this tool to make it pretty
much the same yeah that works okay and
smooth this out a bit yeah that's good
enough for me okay now I need to make
this straight again okay and at the cent
texture over here as well well that's
all good now what I thought about doing
over here is first of all I want to
smooth this out because I don't want
this sticking out but I'm probably going
to add some rocks at some point so I'm
thinking about adding a little very
small mountain with like some foliage on
top of it made and I made out of custom
scenery rocks just to add a nice
transition over there to the ramp like
parts over here and but before I do that
I need to fix the textures over here
because once again I took the wrong
texture as I keep doing that and make
this cross again
open the path cover set again and finish
this oh go on
right now I still have like some stuff
to say but at some point I'm gonna run
out of things to say because this is
very this gets boring and time-consuming
and yeah that's basically that's
basically what this is
I can't sugarcoat this it's just boring
and time-consuming okay oh come on
terraforming is really weird with the
camera because for some reason it just
messes everything up not just a camera
by the way terraforming cometh
everything up so yeah I'll be careful
okay now this is almost finished the
blue cliff site is still bit annoying
quarterhorse again again that blue
cliffside holy [ __ ] and I'm gonna add
some quarters no actually no scrap that
I'm gonna use horse because I can
because I'm gonna have to add these
things anyway you know just like that's
not gonna bring out any further develop
a still need to figure out what I'm
going to do with this area might add a
ride or a building over there if I have
enough time okay now it's time to open
up shy guys plan to stew again for those
awesome rocky walls they actually path
edges but they work great as was let's
see nice nice and
morph over here and the normal hop over
there and we're almost done
oh come on
still not that blue cliff site though
oops okay now at this point that thing
is pretty much done though I forgots
that you could also if you want to do
that you can make this one edge higher
so you can actually have this this kind
of thing going on but I don't think I
really need this not for this coaster I
want the guests to have a really good
view of their own that's their roller
coaster slash I'm probably going to add
a different border on top of that
actually yes I'm just going to
experiment with that let's see I know
there's a border set over here
oh I don't have it anymore um let's see
in any case though I can also use this
set no wait I shouldn't still have that
set let's see oh come on I know after
that sad some where oh wait no then I
don't in any case our multiple sets with
bigger borders and this set is one of
them but I think this set doesn't have
any really good things though this set
does actually a some pretty nice pieces
now I could potentially use but let's
see you know that not too small actually
though no that's going to clip never
mind then
let's check it out with this one I know
that's not going to work is it although
that might actually work somehow
actually that looks pretty cool yeah I
think I'm gonna just go for it though
there are others set like this unless I
I i don't know I know that I other SATs
for this but I clearly just lost them
but this works as well though it's just
one collar that might be a bit too
boring yeah actually I'm going to add a
double calling yeah even better okay
good
now let's do this oh wait well was the
other placement though over there
the names are a bit different but
they're technically the same pieces okay
now I'm just gonna do the two times two
where was the two times two oh god
there's no two times two piece oh damn
well there is a two times one piece
though which doesn't work great this
doesn't work either hmm
this is actually going to be pretty hard
this won't work I might actually have to
change the walls just to make them
conform to this set oh let's see yeah it
doesn't have a 2 x 2 and these 1 x 2 and
other pieces are not quite doing it that
means I'm going to have to do something
else right just great that means I'm
gonna have to remove this remove all of
that and remove this as well and I'm not
I'm gonna I'm not going to make major
changes but I just need to do a slight
change I am going to make the 2 x 2
curve using the diagonal two straight
pieces
okay oops wrong caller right now that
works out yeah that's actually pretty
nice okay so if a set doesn't have a two
times two curved piece you can always
just do this okay
that works out pretty nice um let's see
Shar got splinters again then I would
probably have to add some half pieces
yeah it's more work but whatever it
looks good okay and gonna add these
holes over here okay and then we're done
once again with the walls though did I
just really oh no that's just the
lighting of the set can't do anything
about that
I just figured because you see these
little edges over here and you can see
how the lighting is slightly different
but I can't do anything about that
except for maybe add some pillows or
something like that I'm probably not
going to do that
okay now the rest is just somewhat
easier this is just going to be a simple
diagonal to straight and the rest is
just straight or diagonal
Oh oops once again wrong colors now I
think that would look pretty nice from
now Bart's perspective as well yeah and
this is the kind of thing that you can
add a fence on okay first I'm gonna do
the diagonals so the rest is all
straights okay good so I can just use
control at this point to keep it at the
same height and just fill all that in
all right now this
I'm gonna pick the half again and for
one oops I just messed up on that one
hmm okay I don't think it really matters
by the way on this app because this Sat
has a simple generic this set has
practically no texture but if you do
have a texture that and you place two
objects and they overlap then the
textures are going to clip and if
anything you don't want that so that's
why I removed that one okay now I need
to see if Station Jim's fencing works
well on this this little border thing it
might not actually work I'm pretty sure
it does though let's see by the way I
really like this app because you can
choose three colors for a fence
and these fences are very detailed and
they look great but yeah as you can see
it's floating well then I'm gonna have
to come up with solution for that I
guess or I could just do this actually
that looks pretty cool actually yeah
that does look pretty cool in a way it's
not too high
let's see but would not look cool on the
entire thing because I might just have
to add one but then it's just so high
then it's almost like an extremely high
fence though yeah ah this is too low
this is practically nothing is it and
then this is too high hmm you know what
I'm just gonna test it like this I don't
think I've ever seen this before though
but it kind of works out and yeah I am
I'm just doing random things right now
and it's like a small railing okay that
actually that's actually pretty cool I
didn't even know that myself by the way
you don't want to raise defense every
time you should not point the cursor in
this like towards the cliff sign because
then you have to raise it every time or
use control if you just keep the cursor
on the on the cliff on the terraformed
point itself then it just stays on the
same level without doing anything oh
come on
except for in this case of course
because this is a half placement yeah
that does mess things up okay so I'm
going to have to use control over here
but still this looks pretty cool let's
see take the diagonal two straight
pieces again okay and a small diagonal
piece oh wait this on the diagonal
pieces in this set are small the 1 9 or
piece there is a small weight this cliff
sign is yeah this is just a regular one
okay
and now the curve let's see again
diagonals straights
okay I see that I will need to use a
half piece let's see what's that hot
piece over there it is and then this one
with running is pretty much finished and
now I just need to add some nice rock
work and foliage and lights and cool
stuff eventually it's going to look
pretty cool I think this is just the
general shape and stuff
okay so nama I'm now I'm going to open
one of my favorite sets in this game and
I see that this episode is starting to
get a bit long so I'm going to have to
end it soon but Weber's large rocks or
Weber a big C C's German is actually one
of my favorite rock senses probably my
favorite rock set actually they're
pretty big but rocks for nine and that
was pretty much it rocks for an hyena
pretty small and if you just rotate them
and use different types of textures it's
going to work out for small small kind
of things that you want to make so let's
see I could use this as a base yeah I
guess that works out and use a rock for
over here another rock for over there I
guess wait no this is a bit too close I
want the mountain to be just a bit
smaller and like I said always if you're
doing rock work just use various types
of rocks various shapes and various
textures that's going to look at best so
now these textures are pretty dark
though so probably going to take this
texture as the dark texture and use the
one that I've already used as the light
texture okay let's see mm-hmm
all right that's always been hard to do
this well I think it's a coming along
nicely and I'm just going to open rock
for from this one again to top that all
off I think that's actually good enough
it doesn't look as good from the other
side though so I'm going to add another
rock over here now that's just a small
simple rock formation just to cover that
transition up so that looks pretty cool
I do see that I need to add one more
path copper piece just make it run into
the rocks that should be fine let's see
yeah that's fine and the border will
cover this gap up so that's all fine
okay then
and I probably want to add some rocks
like on the bottom of this thing just
because they look cool so I'm gonna do
that right now
I see open launch rocks again and from
the bottom because this is this is a
pretty big space and you can always just
like the rocks go into this wall I can
use their bigger rock pieces as well
okay where's the set again large rocks
by the way my set I I have to to launch
rocks because I on an accident I made a
copy of this set but I already used that
copy like in a couple of rollercoasters
so I'm going to have to keep it just to
make sure my Park files don't corrupt
and I'm just going to use this these
rocks on the sides
just as a kind of transition to the
ground okay again use various types of
rocks various shapes and various
textures and rotate them now it's
starting to look pretty cool
okay now I'm going to take the other
texture that I used and just add some
rocks of this not going to add too much
rock work because this is still a simple
coaster simple and generic so I'm not
going to make this a rock fest like some
of my coasters are sometimes but still
some rocks are always cool and I want to
have a small rock over here so I'm just
going to use four again same here and
nine probably as well nine is a great
Rock for this for this type of thing
because it's a very small rock but it's
also its shape it's straight shape makes
it perfect for a cliff sides okay then
so I'm just going to add a nine over
here that's starting to look good
okay now I do want some more except this
texture though okay I think that yeah
that's just about enough I'm just gonna
add some more offset rocks because
otherwise it looks too straight and to
man-made it needs to look a bit more
random Winnick when it comes to rock
work by the way if it looks straight and
man-made that's not the way to go and
like always add some random rocks that
are in offset positions just to make it
look random and natural you know just
kind of like this I guess
wait now they're all pointing towards
that direction that's not very nice okay
that that was actually pretty cool I'm
just gonna add one more walk over here
and then I think I'm done yeah okay that
looks pretty cool so in this episode
we've just done this quick path cover
thing over here just as I don't know
what you'd call this I don't even know
but it looks pretty cool so yeah I'm
just gonna go for it
okay so thanks for watching and in the
next episode I am going to try to add
some fences and stuff probably so till
then